I've learned over the years it's not
good for me to see pictures of myself
every day I tend to get triggered by
something whether it's a picture of me
or I feel like I looked like my tummy
was too big or like someone said that I
looked pregnant or something and that'll
just trigger me to just starve a little
bit just stop eating I would have
defended it to anyone who said I'm
concerned about you I was like what are
you talking about of course I eat It's
Perfectly Normal I just exercise a lot
there's always some standard of beauty
that you're not meeting because if
you're thin enough then you don't have
that ass that everybody wants but if
have enough weight on you to have an ass
then your stomach isn't flat enough it's
all just impossible you don't ever say
to yourself like I've got an eating
disorder but you know you're like making
a list of everything you put in your
mouth that day and you know that's
probably not right but then again
there's so many diet blogs that tell you
that that that's what you should do
[Music]
there's a lot to unpack hey everyone I'm
Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
today we're going to be discussing and
actually following Megastar Taylor
Swift's diet with some Abby twists of
course as always I am using her alleged
meals as a template for teaching gentle
nutrition and inspiring what I decide to
make for myself that works for my body
and just my Cravings that day which
means it's not to be replicated by
anyone else I want to also note that
this diet was compiled from primary and
secondary sources so I really cannot
speak to its legitimacy or accuracy now
before we get into the food I want to
talk about this memorable clip from
Taylor Swift's 2020 documentary Miss
Americana in this vulnerable moment
Taylor opens up about her past struggles
with eating and body image that she had
struggled with since living in the
Limelight she discussed obsessive
exercising calorie restriction and
merely fainting in every show but what I
felt was most telling was when she said
this but then again there's so many diet
blogs that tell you that that
that that's what you should do yep even
a mega Superstar multi-millionaire with
all the resources in the world is not
immune to the pressures of diet culture
online she's not necessarily just able
to overlook all the blogs and videos out
there that convince us every day that
eating disorder behaviors are normal and
to be celebrated as Taylor said herself
it's impossible she also makes a
really excellent point in the
documentary that celebrities are
essentially held to an aesthetic
standard of the age in which they got
famous which means that Taylor is
somehow expected to maintain the frame
of a prepubescent girl like a legitimate
child but spoil alert if you guys
haven't watched the documentary yet
Taylor has put these restrictive
behaviors behind her as she has found a
way as she puts it to change the channel
in her brain let me hop in here super
quick to tell you about today's sponsor
homoglob so ask my husband and my
parents for basically anyone else that
has ever lived with me I'm not the
tidiest person in the world world where
I may excel in like my time management
organizational skills I completely fall
apart in my ability to like close a
cupboard door or make my bed I really do
try but between work and my family
responsibilities the house does seem to
get a wee bit cluttered but I mean like
with two boys under five and a dog it
would be kind of creepy not to live in
Perpetual chaos am I right that said a
messy house and workspace often results
in a messy headspace like I sometimes
just feel that I can breathe deeper and
concentrate better when I don't just see
piles of junk everywhere I look so I was
really excited about working with home
glow which is a five-star house cleaning
service at really affordable prices this
service is amazing for families or
single folks who need regular or
occasional cleaning support because
their online booking capabilities let
you instantly schedule a cleaner in your
area on the fly so whether you're
hosting a party need frequent upkeep or
you've been given like a last minute
warning that your in-laws are dropping
by it can take a huge stressor off your
plate to schedule cleaning you simply
head to homoglo's website and choose the
day time and duration for your cleaning
and you can browse the candidates
reviews and background checks before you
book 100 of the fees and tips go
directly to your cleaner and you can pay
per visit or sign up for their forever
ever clean membership to save thirty
dollars an hour on future cleanings so
if cleaning or Tiding often falls to the
bottom of your endless to-do list head
to homeaglow.com Abby sharp to get your
first cleaning for nine dollars and take
one huge mess off your plate so let's
change the channel together today and
eat like our favorite anti-hero The
brilliantly Talented Miss Americana
Taylor Swift Abby please tell me a
foodie Love Story let's do it are you
ready for it I am legit so excited for
today I'm kind of low-key obsessed with
Taylor I think she is a creative
Mastermind like everything is so
meticulously thought through with her
and like all Geniuses she starts her day
with coffee we love to see it so Taylor
apparently self-identifies as a
Starbucks addict same girl same but
unlike me because hashtag budget Taylor
insists on having a Starbucks coffee
every single day on on the weekdays she
goes for a skinny vanilla latte and on
the weekends she's all about the pumpkin
spice latte so it's Friday when I'm
filming this so I don't know if that
constitutes the weekend or a week day
also biggest life question of all time
is Sunday the start of the week or is
Monday I'm team Monday start of the week
Sunday is still fun day in my books what
on Sunday would you say next Monday
no I'd say Monday so would you not say
that that would be the start of the week
then
if you said this Monday
whatever why
okay I feel stupid now anyways let's
order a coffee and we gotta do it Taylor
style spend the dough
and get ourselves a box
I was gonna go with her weekend option
because a I don't like skim milk um but
B I just want it to be the weekend but
apparently they're not serving the
pumpkin spice anymore it's a dead of
winter so yeah I guess I gotta go with
the skinny vanilla latte better than no
latte
it's not bad it's sweet I don't love the
kind of faux sweetener but if Taylor's
into it I'm gonna do it for her
okay so you know what I say about coffee
you drink it how you like it but I want
those of you who have a similar kind of
healthy in the week and go ham on the
weekend routine to get curious about
your why I don't know Taylor's intention
or rationale but generally when there's
a rule like this especially one that
explicitly juxtaposes being good and
being bad at last skinny it may keep us
trapped in scarcity mentality which can
ultimately wear away at a relationship
with food and this is a super benign
example in my opinion like it's a coffee
drink with a bad name whatever you do
you but if you find yourself always
eating clean in the week and then
indulging on the weekend it may be worth
reevaluating your rationale for these
rules I'm not at a point in this day
where i'm like ready to fully unpack
this because my latte has not yet
arrived but we're not out of the woods
yet friends I'm gonna Circle back to
this topic real soon I'm feeling a lot
more like myself now so let's talk about
breakfast so Taylor cold Bon Appetit
that her go-to breakfast is buckwheat
crepes with ham parmesan cheese and a
fried egg on top with some freshly
squeezed
orange juice girl my go-to breakfast is
like a latte I make myself some peanut
butter toast that I whip up as I run out
the door and usually my kids snotty
leftovers in a bowl the mucus Queen is
yours but I'm definitely not mad about
this though I know people are definitely
going to have something to say and some
questions about the ham situation Abby
what's the deal on deli meats so the
research on Ultra processed Meats like
deli meats is as usual a little bit
complicated one 2022 review found that
processed meats and red meats were
significantly associated with an
increased risk of mortality yet another
2022 review including over a million
participants examining the link between
Type 2 diabetes and Ultra processed
foods found a dose response effect aka
the dose makes the poison now in terms
of the common claim that Ultra processed
Meats cause cancer a 2019 meta-analysis
including studies following patients
anywhere between 2 to 30 four years old
found low to very low evidence that
lowering consumption of red and
processed Meats resulted in very small
decreases in cancer incidents as well as
cardiometabolic outcomes and all-cause
mortality so I don't suggest eating deli
meats every single day it is a
convenient source of protein iron and B
vitamins and fine in moderation as for
the nitrate argument again the dose
makes the poison and I've got a whole
video unpacking those questions right
here
okay it's been a while since I've made
Crepes so I am going to do my best to
follow the instructions on this one I
need two and a half cups of water
to
one and a half cups of buckwheat flour
again you're not supposed to do this
one
yeah that'll do
two then half a teaspoon of salt
and half teaspoon of baking soda
I mean sounds pretty simple
very thin
okay I'm gonna let it sit
for a little bit annoying I just need so
many steps a few minutes later hi major
skepticism here folks major skepticism
Maybe
might work
[Laughter]
[Applause]
still wet it's stressful
like I'm not great at flipping pancakes
never mind a crepe that is edge to edge
in My Pan and I'm definitely going to
burn my fingers just trying to get it
off
what's the technique here oh oh
maybe I should have let it sit longer
pretend that side
well you know what they always say the
first one's always a bust it's just the
practice round clearly I needed more
time oh no it really stuck
oh
there we go
nice even coating let's try this again
take two
I believe in you
just having a mindful meditate
meditation moment praying to The Crepe
Gods I just need one good crepe just one
is that too much to ask for I think I
need to somehow flip it oh I have I've
got I've got an idea again as you can
see I'm not following a recipe I'm just
trying to use my intuition here but you
still have to
slide it off onto the plate first that's
the thing or else you're just going to
put it right back on the same way I have
to slide it off yeah because then you
have to flip it anyway I was going to
just dump it
yeah but then you'd have to flip it
anyway again
pop it
all right I got a better idea we're just
going to use the whole grain wrap
Friday because that I feel like I can do
a shell
yeah
fiber all right we're gonna slap down
some ham
because I'm in a bad mood now
that took a lot of energy and it was not
worth it ham down
now Taylor didn't include any veg but I
am going to add some spinache that I've
got
and I've got some leftover mushrooms and
onions here from dinner last night
always a natural panning
I'm gonna throw
some cheese down parmesan
lots of it apparently
and
what else has to go in here egg cheese I
mean that's all she said
I guess we just need to warm it up one
sec
should I put it back in the pan what is
happening I think I will just it gets
crispy we're really we're really uh
freestyling here folks
living on the edge
let's do a recap the buckwheat crepe was
a bust but I have a whole grain crepe
here and if you ask me it looks like a
buckwheat crepe yet it was a lot more
Cooperative so take a tip folks so we
got some carbs and fiber in our wrap
plus all of our fruit that I added on
the side and some extra veggies I snuck
in there as well we've got some protein
in the ham and the Egg lots of fats as
well from the cheese egg ham all the
good stuff
um I'm pretty excited about this it was
a lot of work but mainly because step
one failed so miserably
hmm
the caramelized onions totally made it
you belong to me
all right got some fuel in the tank now
it's time for some movement so according
to WebMD Taylor loves to run of course
she does
um and yes that does make sense I guess
because stage work is like like an
Olympic sport very very physical heavy
cardio going on but Taylor didn't have
two big boys smash out her lady flower
and cause severe prolapse and diastases
so I'm gonna pass on the running if you
don't mind but Taylor is also super into
Body by Simone's dance slash bodyweight
workout and I found one on YouTube it's
20 minutes very doable so let's try it
[Music]
all right got a little bit of work done
let's talk about lunch so Taylor told
WebMD that during the week she tries to
eat healthily so that means salads
yogurts and sandwiches note the whole
healthy during the week thing but I
digress uh in an interview with World
magazine she specifically mentioned
really liking to make tomato pesto
mozzarella paninis and of course some
salads with lots of veggies or fish this
sounds great totally sounds like a meal
I want to put together let's get to it
first step a little pesto
maybe a lot of pesto I don't know I like
the flavor of pesto so I'm going to load
her up you can make your own pesto but
mama don't have time so store-bought
cheers it smells amazing
[Music]
um
lots of
stuff now
cheese on top
a little tomato action yeah
yeah look how good this is all right and
then lots of cheese
and because it's a panini I feel like we
should like warm it up on the stove
so let's get to that just gotta give it
some time here folks go to bed go to bed
my friend go to bed
[Music]
well that's toasting up we'll just make
a little side salad here some some
Tomatoes some bell pepper let's do some
of this avocado here Boop
la la la la la la
what else oh get some chickpeas because
we want to add a little extra protein in
this meal
beep beep gotta get those chickpea skins
out
cheese action we want to go feta or yeah
let's just do the feta
add a few little nuts for some extra
crunch
and I got this really good Green Goddess
dressing
it's like it's gonna just kind of there
you go there you go all right let's
recap we got carbs in our bread we've
got protein in the chickpeas plus the
cheese and the nuts healthy fats in the
pesto nuts and the avocado and tons of
fiber going on and she is a thing of
beauty
hmm
look what you made me do look what you
made me do look what you made me do look
what you made me do
terrible
this sandwich turned out all too well
okay so I'm gonna go grab my kids from
school shortly and usually the first
thing that they ask for when they get in
the car is a snack
so I found this recipe called the Swift
shake that Dr Oz designed for Taylor
Swift
um and ironically it's not a shake which
is confusing it's more like energy balls
which sound awesome because my kids love
an energy ball so let's try them out
three quarters of a cup
of flaxseed
I feel like we don't need to be that
specific with this recipe
okay quarter cup of peanut butter
enough
little squirt of honey
uh
dried cranberries
quarter cup
and some dark chocolate chips
okay so according to our buddy
Dr Oz
we mix it together
a lot of flax so I guess it's got to
like kind of Clump okay you mix it
together and then according to Dr Oz you
just like shake it into clumps
oh
I see what he did like
shake shake shake it off
[Music]
this is looking terrible really like we
couldn't have just rolled them into
balls looks like someone took it's like
poppy puked on them on my uh plate here
yeah it looks like with some like she
got into the dry cranberries maybe a few
chocolate chips Not Unusual for her all
right well I guess that's that I mean
let's try them I mean we can't knock it
till we try them
oh
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope
I need a lot of water well this day has
not gone well for me uh yeah they're
definitely nutritious we got lots of
fiber healthy fats in those flax and the
peanut butter protein all the good stuff
but they look like my dog's diarrhea and
they're going to be a bloody mess to
take these into the car with the kids ah
would you ever feed these to Children
you are asking for a full-on disaster
Bobby are cranberries safe for dogs
chocolate's not oh
foreign
I don't even think you'd eat this well
another day another lesson of what not
to do okay let's talk dinner so
apparently dinner also kind of depends
on if Taylor is living her like weekday
or weekend life
um on the weekday Taylor told World
magazines that she makes a mean barbecue
chicken and also really great pasta
dishes like her shrimp scampi or chicken
with capers she's also a huge Barefoot
Contessa fan me as well and some of her
favorite recipes are the mustard roasted
fish and spaghetti and meatballs as for
the weekend she told Bon Appetit that
she loves Comfort foods like burgers
fries ice cream Etc and she's not fancy
about it either she loves to dip her
french fries into like the Wendy's
frosties or have like a McFlurry from
McDonald's a girl after my own heart she
also apparently loves the chicken
nuggies at McDonald's and she's a big
fan of burritos with added chips for
some extra crunch hello and you know
what I definitely want to try out that
whole burrito hack and I want to
demonstrate how we can make weekend food
like for the weekdays and vice versa and
speaking of this whole weekend weekday
dichotomy Abby can you give us some
thoughts okay so let's finally talk
about this reoccurring theme of like
weekday food and weekend food this
concept may be completely common and
normalized but it is ultimately grounded
in diet cultures notorious dichotomous
All or Nothing thinking you're either
being good or eating bad you're eating
clean or having a cheat I mean if this
is something that you regularly do
yourself know that you are not alone but
I invite you to get curious on the why
like what's the fear or anxiety
motivating these rules why can we have
like full sugar full fat lattes on a
Sunday but we have to drink skim milk
and sweetener in the week why can't we
have Comfort Foods on a random Tuesday
what would happen if we were to choose
two other completely arbitrary days to
indulge ultimately this concept may seem
benign and to a lot of folks it totally
is but if you have a history with
disordered eating it can be a slippery
slope personally I know that when I kind
of physically recovered from my eating
disorder so like I was weight restored
and I also wasn't having obsessive
thoughts about counting calories or over
exercising but I still found it really
hard to truly let go of some of this
kind of weekend weekday structure and
this kept me from truly reaching food
freedom for a very long time because
even though I would occasionally allow
myself The Forbidden Foods it wasn't
necessarily when I actually wanted them
the most it was when the rule said I
could have them and that actually
perpetuated a lot of body distrust
because I was eating when I was full and
satisfied and not eating when my body
and mind craved it Taylor herself
reported to Bon Appetit that she keeps a
supply of binge Foods in the house like
ready-made cinnamon rolls or a container
of cookie dough and I'm not suggesting
that this is disorderly or an eating
disorder binge but it's a good reminder
that old habits do die hard and we can
be physically recovered while still
putting out little fires everywhere true
recovery is potentially a lifelong
process so in situations like this my
gentle nutrition suggestion would be to
challenge those rules see what it would
feel like for you to have a full fat
latte or ice cream in the week is it
scary is it a relief and what happens on
the weekends with those novelty Foods
when you have allowed yourself access
all week long research suggests that one
of the greatest predictors of a binge is
restriction and when we allow ourselves
unconditional permission to eat the
foods that we love we knock them off of
their pedestal they lose their moral
power we can have our dessert without
obsessing that it will be the last sweet
nothing we can get our little paws on
all week because I'm not going to make a
burrito after I just made failed Crepes
okay come at me
all right
got a fat oh my God it smells good
I'm not sure which one
is a witch
did you get
burrito sauce has has only burrito sauce
that's mine
this one's yours
she's heavy she's
heavy we we went to town with the
toppings over here
[Music]
skip the workout
all right
is this gonna be
oh yeah look at that bad boy
she was called a fat bastard for a
reason okay let's get
some
hello Mama okay I just want to say that
I know that this is part of Taylor's
like weekend food regimen but the renos
are actually apparently pretty well
balanced so like we've got lots of
protein in our chicken and our beans we
have tons of veggies I put in here for
some fiber plus we've got the guacamole
which they added no charge love that uh
for some healthy fats and some extra
fiber cheese in there for some fats I
got some hot sauce and some salsa for
some extra flavor I mean it looks so
good and we have to try this hat how do
we do this
this did not come with instructions
it's probably gonna cut my mouth
like a razor
hmm
soap
good Taylor
you are a genius
hmm now I'm definitely craving something
sweet and I know that Taylor apparently
loves to bake so according to Bon
Appetit she is big on baking cookies and
pumpkin cake and I actually made her
chai cookies in my holiday video and
they were so good so I found this Reddit
thread here
um where like all of her Die Hard fans
have compiled all of Taylor's favorite
recipes I love it and like all the
little desserts that she's made online
and she's definitely into the Fall
pumpkin flavor so it's like lots of
pumpkin recipes here and we love to see
it I also am obsessed with pumpkin
everything so we're gonna do a really
super simple pumpkin loaf cake with like
a cream cheese swirl because cream
cheese frosting makes everything way
better let's do it okay so I'm gonna try
my best to read the recipe
because you guys know I suck at that in
general and I will inevitably mess this
up I've already messed it up in terms of
the measurement cups but it's asking for
three quarters of pumpkin puree I've got
a half a cup here I'm gonna just have to
eyeball the half a cup that looks about
half
should measure but I can't bring myself
to it's like a compulsion just can't do
it okay eggs one two
what's the worst
oh guys I only do this when Brody's
watching honestly I never
I'm really good at
cooking and baking and oh my God
when Everyone's Watching I just get so
skin my head
hitting the game all right eggs in
vanilla
um sugar that we need a lot of
and I'm not gonna like try to helpify
this like that I'm not using date sugar
coconut sugar maple syrup it doesn't
actually matter folks like it's all the
same and I want to just do it the way
that Taylor does it so I'm gonna follow
the recipe oh
Brody's shaking his head at me
sorry I'll just do a little bit less on
this one I mean I definitely learned in
culinary school you're definitely never
supposed to measure ingredients over the
bowl because that's exactly what
happened
but whatever I don't want to make like a
big to do out of this it's just it's
just pumpkin bread guys I'm not making a
souffle okay I'll add the pumpkin's pie
spice while we're waiting
God
I'm melting butter and literally every
single time I do this it just explodes
in my microwave oh I caught it right the
next time okay so already I'm uh
deviating from what the recipe says the
recipe calls for a half a cup of
vegetable oil I probably have vegetable
oil but my little culinary hack is when
they ask for vegetable oil go for butter
like it just tastes better and if you
have the butter yes it's more expensive
there's no question and I'm not doing
this in some kind of like Health move I
don't give a about using vegetable
oil and baked goods but I just think it
tastes better every time tastes like
more homemade more like your grandmother
made it right because Grandma's always
used butter now there's eggs in this
mixture so I've got to go slow because I
just melted this and I don't want it to
scramble my eggs so
that's down it smells so effing good
what's gonna make it smell even better
is the pumpkin pie spice so one teaspoon
and a half a teaspoon let's go with if
you need a teaspoon and a half one
two
three
great I have to add salt half a teaspoon
in
uh what else what else what else baking
powder
two teaspoons
I'm a little shaky today I've had a lot
of caffeine
because your girl woke up at three A.M
couldn't get back to sleep so I just
kind of
came down and started my morning ritual
um one cup and three quarters of a cup
okay
again
you're not supposed to do this I would
have failed
my class if I did this the great thing
about being an adult
so you can do whatever the you want
and no one can tell you differently
until the internet comes at me because I
picked up a simple loaf cake that looks
about three quarters of a cup X
okay
now we mix this is like almost as messy
as when I allow my children to accompany
me in the kitchen
to make cake
[Music]
all right let's make the cream cheese
bit because that looks
amazing okay eight ounces cream cheese
softened I'm hoping this is softened
enough because as usual
I forgot even set myself an alarm to
take it out of the fridge and I still
forgot so I welcome to my life key is to
just like cut it into small bits so that
you can
blend it up better
okay
one egg
that's my lipstick
they said it's long wear
that my friends was a lie more sugar
that's good
more vanilla oh that wasn't supposed to
be vanilla in the other part but
No One's Gonna Be No it's not vanilla's
never ruined any recipe and then a
little bit of flour apparently I better
make sure that that's supposed to be
Express those secret ingredient for
pancakes flour vanilla
even though like everybody that's not
secret like I know we just let
them have it that's so funny you're like
um but everyone does that it's like a
little cinnamon for a Special Touch
that's the Family secret recipe
[Music]
I badly want to eat this but there's raw
egg on it and I know the comment section
will be full of trolls even though guys
I know you all do it too so we've all
had our fair share of raw batter
um all right we need a loaf pan so
apparently half goes down
then we put the cream cheese frosting
layer
that's a generous amount of uh
cream cheese yeah that's what she looks
like and I'm here for it
it's tough to be patient it's not my
forte I kind of uh
not sure if that was half and half but
we're working with it
you know what
it's gonna be just fine I might even do
a swirl for some decorative
flare
what also the butter hack try it next
time
this is going to a 325 degree oven for
like an hour it takes a long time one
hour later
this makes up for that shake because it
smells amazing I'm so excited to dig in
as you can see we've had a rough day
here
have I cleaned as I went no it's been
busy okay
here we go
oh my God nobody wants the end
but even that looks holy good
foreign
this
Perfection all in its own but I feel
like because I'm having this right
before bed I know that I need a really
satiating bedtime snack so I'm gonna
serve it with a little bit of Greek
yogurt right on the side here and a
couple blueberries
or some extra fiber and
some pecans as well just for that extra
little bit
of crunch and fat I cannot wait for this
I cannot wait
I'm so excited oh no I'm just going in
this is not sweet nothings this is sweet
everything
so today was a bit of a mixed bag
experience for me personally on the
bright side we didn't get any like
pseudoscience Wellness hacks or like
overtly obnoxiously diety foods and the
fact that I didn't have to debunk lemon
water for once was a huge plus not to
mention the burrito hack and that
pumpkin cake
oh mind blown I could eat that all day
every day that said crepe gate and the
shake balls situation
left a little bit to be desired it had
potential but it just slightly missed
the Mark I ended up doing like a
combination of Taylor's weekday and
weekend eats because I know personally
that is what helped me in my
relationship with food now I'm not
suggesting that Taylor is struggling
with disordered eating or an e disorder
but I just want to note that recovery is
not just like a switch that you can turn
on or off I'm like over a decade after
my own recovery and I still have
thoughts that I need to work through
because for me they're grounded in
something a lot bigger than my body and
food for me personally it often has a
lot to do with my anxiety which is kind
of obsessive compulsive flavored I have
a super type A personality and I
consider myself a highly sensitive
person we're all humans this is so
complicated and we are all so unique but
I really do feel that I identify with
Taylor in a lot of ways both
professionally and personally this clip
right here could have easily just come
straight right out of my own diary you
know my entire moral code as a kid and
now is a need to be thought of as good
do the right thing do the good thing
overall the main thing that I always
tried to be was
um like a good girl I've been trained to
be happy when you get a lot of Praise I
had that Praise of Taylor you're doing a
good job at your work you're doing a
good job at being a songwriter and doing
a good job of being musician like those
pats on the head were all I lived for
this is a glaring metaphor for diet
culture in my books certain foods get
labeled as good or clean and others as
bad or dirty in turn people morally feel
good or bad for eating those foods and
when we get praise for our dedication or
our commitment or our shrinking body it
reinforces that this is what we need to
do this is what we need to do to be
loved and reveal weird being an
emotionally and physically smaller
person and when you're in the spotlight
I can imagine it's virtually impossible
to escape this but everyone please
repeat after me I am worthy of foods
that nourish my body physically and
emotionally regardless of whether or not
it's a Tuesday or a Saturday I am worthy
of praise and approval and respect
regardless of my body shape size or what
I put on my plate well folks that's all
the Taylor references that I got and I
hope this video was helpful for you on a
multitude of levels if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on Whose diet you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
thank you